i think one of the worst things you can
do especially to a young person
is to convince them that they're some
kind of victim and that the world is
against them and that they're oppressed
especially if that's not
actually true because i believe that
whatever lens you view the world through
is gonna be your reality
[Music]
hey and welcome this is the ben shapiro
show sunday special i'm excited to
welcome to the show independent rapper
host of real talk with zoo bee podcast
the author of strong advice
zubi's guide to fitness for everybody if
you didn't know it's zooby zubi thanks
so much for stopping by dude really
appreciate it
man i'm happy to be here well the first
i had seen of any of your work obviously
it wasn't rap because as we will discuss
i have some differences with you on rap
and i'm going to have you convince me
that i really
ought to listen to more rap but the
first i was aware of you was when you
cut that hilarious video that obviously
went viral of you breaking every
women's weightlifting record in the uk
in one
session basically while identifying as a
woman now did they
number one what was the origin of that
particular idea number two did they
actually
change the books to reflect the fact
that as a woman you had now destroyed
all of the records
okay so well how do i start with this so
those videos were actually just from
some of my random training sessions so i
didn't
actually enter a sanctioned powerlifting
meet and officially
break the records but i had the videos
on my phone and i'd seen a whole bunch
of stories popping up
on my timeline about transgender women
beating biological women in their own
sports it was happening in athletics and
weightlifting all these kind of things
so just out of curiosity i did a google
search just to see what the power
lifting
records were in britain for females
in my own weight class and i saw them
all and i was like oh i can
i can beat these quite comprehensively
so
i just did a search on my phone and i
had videos of training clips of me
lifting more than those so i literally
just created that first deadlift tweet
so it was it was a video that already
existed on my phone um and it was
already on the internet but without any
context except it being from my training
session so i just wrote that caption you
know i keep hearing about
how biological men have no physical
advantage over women so watch me destroy
the british women's deadlift record
without trying and i really wasn't
trying in that video because that video
was
about 60 kilos 100 pounds below my
maximum
which was kind of the point because i'm
not even a competitive athlete so i just
put that out there
thinking it would get a couple of laughs
from my existing audience and lo and
behold it
took over the internet for a couple of
days and got international coverage and
now here we are no how dare you sir
first of all how dare you i mean
pointing out that there are average
differences
in biology between men and women this
obviously is untouchable did you get any
serious blowback from people over over
the point that you were making
which really has nothing to do with
transgender rights or anything like that
the serious point that you are making is
that obviously there are biological
differences between men and women did
you what was the blowback like from that
yeah
so the firstly the support was huge the
support was
gigantic um i even had you know i've got
followers who are trans and i've had
lots of messages from people who are
actually trans
saying dude that was hilarious that's
right because
they understand yeah they understand the
reality they they got the humor
there was a very tiny tiny percentage of
people less than one percent of people
who responded to it who were trying to
attribute some kind of malice to what i
was doing there were people who were
angry at it for
different reasons though people who
didn't understand it some people were
angry at me saying that what i did was
unfor
unfair towards women they were like hey
you're not you're not really a woman
that's not fair what you did was messed
up you took away the record from women
but that was kind of like that's the
point you kind of got the point but
you've also really really missed it here
and then there were also other people
trying to say that it came from some
place of
hatred towards transgender people or
lgbt people as a whole which of course
it wasn't
um some people were saying oh well you
didn't go on the hormone therapy so
you're not really this or you're not
really that and
i'm pretty sure even if i did go on
hormone therapy for one year i wouldn't
exactly be
equivalent to someone born a female but
um
yeah there was a little bit of blowback
as expected just given how many people
ended up seeing it i mean millions of
people saw that
but overall overwhelmingly it was
positive and people understood what i
was getting at
so for folks who don't know anything
about your profile you have this very
eclectic profile we're an independent
rapper
and you have a book about fitness and
also you're a grad of oxford
so what's your life story how did you
get to the point where you're now here
sitting in the studio
yeah sure so the abbreviated life story
of zubi i was born in the uk
i actually moved to the middle east i
lived in saudi arabia
i moved there when i was one my parents
worked out there for a couple of decades
my dad's a doctor
and uh like your wife my mom was working
as a journalist at the time
so uh we lived in saudi arabia i went to
school there
up until uh fifth grade so when i was 11
i went to boarding school in the uk at
the age of 11.
so i was back and forth between the two
countries for a long time did really
well in school
got into oxford university and went
there to study computer science
so i did that for three years when i was
in my first year i started rapping
when i was a kid i used to play piano so
i did some music in the past then i also
played trombona in a band for a while
and then i kind of fell out of love with
music and
fell back into it i was a hip-hop fan in
my teen years at school
and then i started rapping in university
and discovered i had a knack for writing
lyrics and
performing so i released my first album
commercial underground when i was
19 and put that out just independently
sold a few thousand copies and that kind
of set the spark of oh this may be
something i can
i can do something with so i graduated
moved to london
i worked as a management consultant
actually for a couple of years whilst
juggling my music stuff on the side
and then in november 2011 i took the
plunge and said hey i'm gonna go and
pursue my music stuff full-time and uh i
haven't starved to death yet so
i'm doing something right and then other
things have been added to the mix
as time has gone on so this year i
started my podcast real talk with zubi i
wrote and released my first book
strong advice in terms of the fitness
stuff i've been training for
over half my life so i figured yo why
don't i
put something together here that can
help people so
i put that out this year uh started
doing a little bit more public speaking
and stuff like that you know i'm just
trying to fulfill my potential basically
because music is the core of what i do
it's something i'm extremely passionate
about
but i'm aware that i have a lot to offer
beyond
just the music you know i've got
something to add to the conversation
there's stuff i can help people with in
terms of fitness and developing a
stronger mindset and stuff like that and
all those avenues are things i'm trying
to
contribute to the world in a positive
way really so i have many many questions
i'm gonna get to all of them in just one
second but first i used to go to the
post office all the time and then i
realized that i didn't have to go to the
post office anymore which is great
because
the post office is wonderful but who
wants to spend the time in the car and
you're schlepping the packages and then
you have to wait in the line
instead you can do everything from home
you can do it from your computer
stamps.com they bring all the amazing
services of the us postal office
directly to your computer whether you're
a small office sending invoices or an
online seller shipping out products
even a warehouse sending thousands of
packages a day stamps.com can handle it
all
with ease simply use your computer to
print official us postage
24 7 for any letter any package any
class of mail
anywhere you want to send it once your
mail is ready you just hand it to your
mail carrier or you drop it in a mailbox
it is indeed
that simple with stamps.com you get five
cents off every first class stamping up
to 40
off priority mail stamps.com is a
no-brainer it saves you time
it saves you money it means no more time
in the car it means no more time waiting
in line it's no wonder over 700 000
small businesses
already use stamps.com look it's
fantastic you used to have to go to the
post office or the grocery store to get
your stamps you have to wait in that
checkout line not anymore right now
my listener has got a special offer it
includes a four-week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale
no long-term commitment just go to
stamps.com click on that microphone at
the top of the home page
type in shapiro that is stamps.com enter
shapiro
so first of all what was it like to live
in saudi arabia i mean i didn't know
that part of your profile
what was that actually like as somebody
who for
one particular reason is not allowed in
saudi arabia what exactly was that like
for you
um i actually really liked it where i
grew up was it was kind of like a bubble
it was an
expert community so you had people there
from all over um
usa canada uk it's why my accent doesn't
even sound british because
i lived in saudi arabia and i was in the
american school system for such a long
time
and i'm someone who's really hard to
influence so even when i went to the uk
my accent just didn't really
shift too much but it was a great place
to grow up
really like diversity in the true sense
of the word i was surrounded by people
of
all different nationalities different
religions different races whatever just
from from the very very beginning
um which is part of why i find some of
the
identity politics stuff that's happening
now really really weird because i didn't
grow up
with any of that it wasn't a thing um
but yeah great place to go to school had
a lot of good friends there
some of whom are still there in terms of
what it looks like it's weird being in
la because
it looks really similar and the
temperature and climate is actually
really really similar
and the roads and the trees everything
like that so just as we were you know
driving around the place i've been
thinking man this reminds me of saudi
but um overall i have a very positive
view of the place i know it's one of
those countries that a lot of people
have
negative views of um
and i can understand some of that but
there's also a lot of
pros to it and the way they there's a
lot of things i think
that country could learn from a place
like the us or uk
but there's also stuff i think the us
and uk could learn from a country like
saudi arabia
which people might be surprised to hear
and what are some of the things you
think that
the the west could learn from from saudi
arabia well
i think firstly it's a very you know i
know you're a religious person i'm a
religious person it's a very
totally god-fearing country everybody is
on the same page so that like it has
it has its benefits and it has its its
drawbacks in terms of
the rules and the laws and whatnot it's
pretty strict
and there's some stuff that maybe people
in the west may think should be allowed
which is
which is not allowed there but when it
comes to things like i'd say
a lot of the social issues and problems
that are
made major issues in the modern western
world
they hardly exist over there right so if
you're talking about broken families or
fatherless homes or you know
yeah kids growing up without parents
drug drug addiction
alcoholism and alcohol problems all that
it's just
it's just not a thing there because
alcohol is illegal
there's no drugs and
again peop everybody people fear god so
you find people there are very honest
actually people are extremely honest
very
hospitable very traditional in certain
senses so
it's easy it's an easy place to
criticize for a lot of reasons but
it does have its benefits to society in
terms of just things
working and functioning and people kind
of being on the same
page and just knowing okay this is how
we do things
respect it take it or leave it and um
it's a weird
it's a weird one to balance but as
someone who lived there for 19 years you
can you can certainly see
how it works and it's not all bad in the
way that people
seem to think that it is i mean you have
this really iconoclastic world view
where you talk a lot about
responsibility and you're obviously
anti-identity politics what do you think
shaped them you talked a little bit
obviously already about the fact that
you grew up in a diverse community
but identity politics is so much a part
of modern politics and it's something
that
i deplore a lot of people on the
political right and many in the
political center seem to deploy but it
obviously is a serious force
in both european politics and certainly
in american politics
what do you make of the the upswing in
identity politics people seeming to
identify by
racial group or ethnic group rather than
identifying as individuals
i think it's a shame i think it's a huge
step backwards
like i said all throughout my life
whether it's
what my my parents and my family taught
me or
the schooling i went through both in
saudi and in the uk and even even up
through university none of this
a lot of these talking points just were
not a thing it was
it seemed like people had moved past all
that stuff obviously it was a
major problem in the past and it still
is
in certain countries but it seemed like
in the mid 2010s or early 2010s suddenly
people started falling back into this
sort of
racial identitarianism there's a version
of it on
the far right there's a version of it on
on the far left and
they don't seem to want to accept the
fact that they're actually kind of
similar to each other in a lot of ways
their motives and wording of stuff might
be a little bit different but they're
kind of playing
the same game and i'm very much an
individualist
who's just like look i don't care where
you're from i don't care what skin color
you are i don't care what
sexuality you are all that all that kind
of stuff it seems so
obvious and basic and people do say it
but then a lot of people the way they
behave
and the rhetoric they use it starts
defying
what they're claiming to to
to talk about so yeah i'd say it it
lines with just
my own personality and then where i was
raised
my my own family my parents it was just
never
a thing they never they never sat me
down and were like oh zooby you're
you're you're black and we're black so
life is going to be
harder for you or you're going to have
to work tens you know all that
stuff there's something that people call
the talk and i never got the talk in
that sense
which i'm very grateful for because i
think one of the worst things you can do
especially to a young person
is to convince them that they're some
kind of victim and that the world is
against them and that they're oppressed
especially if that's not
actually true because i believe that
whatever lens you view the world through
is gonna be your reality if you walk
around thinking that
the the whole society of nation is very
very racist and very very sexist and
very very bigoted
you'll start to see those things even
where they don't exist
right you'll you'll get onto a bus and
the bus driver might be a little bit
rude to you and you'll say oh
he was like that to me because i'm black
or because i'm a woman or because
whereas it might just be that he's not a
very nice guy who's in a bad mood
whatever right so you start you start
reading intentions that may not
even be there and you're seeing people
doing this a lot now
right you're hearing people talking
about things like the rise of white
supremacy and
things and i'm like what where is this
is the kkk
coming back if they are then let me know
because i need to be aware right but
you're having people just saying these
terms and saying putting things out
there and really
catastrophizing in a way and i just
don't think it's helpful to people like
i said i just don't think you want to be
convincing people
that they are victims that they're
oppressed
and then getting mad at them getting
i've had people get mad at me for
telling them i'm not oppressed
which to me is the most bizarre thing
i've literally been in arguments with
people where they're trying to convince
me i'm impressed i'm like
no i'm good like i'm i'm very very
privileged right
90 99 of the people in the world would
probably quite
happily swap positions with me and then
just having that perspective like my
family background is also from nigeria
so in terms of
just having a global perspective on
things and
seeing just how fortunate we are if you
live in the uk if you live in the us
just you're in such a good position
right people like to talk about the one
percent it's like
most the people talking about that are
in the one percent globally and i just
don't think a lot of people
realize that and feel that sense of
gratitude and perspective for where they
are so that's something that's very much
ingrained in me
um and yeah i think that helps to shape
my worldview a lot
it's interesting i mean i talk to a lot
of folks on the left obviously i have
friends on the left
many of whom are people of color and
there is this constant conversation
about systems of oppression systemic
oppression in the united states
institutional racism the legacy of
vestiges of the past jim crow and
slavery you know i don't even like the
term people of color
i don't use it because why do we need it
why do we need a term that just means
non-white no really
like i i i wrote this on twitter it went
kind of viral i said something like
i don't use the term people of color
because it's only neces you only need
that delineation if you're a clansman
or you're a radical leftist right what's
the term for people who are not black
there isn't one
all right there's no there's no word for
that so why would i need a word
for everybody who's not white because i
don't i don't see the world that way
so okay i have some black friends and my
black friends tell me
some black friends on the left who who
really do focus in a lot on what they
believe to be
the imbalances of power between white
folks and black folks in
the united states primarily because
they're not european uh and they talk
about the disparities in terms of
systemic oppression institutional racism
and vestiges
of old institutions so you see for
example the new york times in the last
few weeks pushing what they call the
16-19 project the idea that the united
states was founded and steeped in racism
and white supremacy and that all of the
institutions are corrupted at root level
by slavery and that capitalism is a
vestige of slavery that all inequalities
i mean my investigate has always been
that of course these are
realities particularly in the past i
mean there's no way to deny the evil of
slavery nor should anybody
no way to deny the evil of jim crow nor
should anybody it's very important to
understand that stuff
when it comes to helping people in the
here and now i'm not sure how it helps
people in the here and now
to tell them that the obstacles that
they face in their life
are vestiges of an unchangeable system
that is rooted in the american or
western dna
when it seems to me that the vast
majority of of
going forward inequality is not going to
be driven by systemic oppression
uh it's it's going to be driven by
individual decision making and people
making good decisions are going to be
able to rise
in the society where do you come down on
that particular debate yeah i mean i
i mostly agree with you there i mean i
think at some point it's
it's important to acknowledge history
and i think
most people regardless of their
political leanings do that and they're
like look
in the past human beings have done a lot
of messed up stuff
and there's no question that black
americans historically
have suffered direct oppression
all the way through to not so
not so long ago and i don't think
there's any question that there are
still
after effects and aftershock of that
so it's one of those situations where a
lot of people want to be like
either or and they want to view it as
some binary either everything is
everything is systemic and everything is
institutionalized and everything has a
problem with the system
or go completely on this other side and
say everything is down to
you know individual choices and what i
think the truth is
both of those have elements of truth in
them
i would say that for looking ahead
looking for
people who exist now people are in the
future no but nobody now
nobody who exists now was ever a slave
nor were their parents
nor has any noise do they hold slaves
neither neither did their parents
so i think you can acknowledge the
history and say okay look this is
where things have come from but then
look at okay what are the
current problems that are happening
amongst
certain communities right now okay if
you removed
racism from the heart of every american
in the world with some of these problems
that are facing you could say
i don't really use the term black
community because it's it's too broad
but if you look at some of the problems
with you know black americans or the
black american community to use the
terminology are facing
i'd say a big one is um has to do you
know a lot of it stems from family
okay a lot of it stems from family
fatherless homes it's like this big
elephant in the room that a lot of
people don't really want to
address just the way people treat each
other
the way people value or don't value
life to some degree and this is
generally still talking about a very
small minority of a minority
but those are real problems and those
are not problems that exist
because of racism okay
um people focus on
when it comes to something
institutionalized or systemic a lot of
people would focus on on the justice
system right
so people will say oh well you know
there might be
um i haven't looked at all the data on
this but i know a lot of people say that
black people may get longer sentences
for the same crime or
some people think that police are kind
of just going around
randomly shooting black men which i
don't really think is uh
i think those are the ones that get the
most media attention but if you look at
the data it doesn't really seem to
fit that narrative and from from what
i've seen i mean i used i used to
believe that too until i looked at the
wider picture and was like okay well
what what else is happening here that's
not being reported and i was like the
narrative isn't
quite as simple as as people are saying
here so
my point is that if you removed racism
completely those issues that i've just
talked about
for the most part would still continue
to exist and persist
which would suggest to me that that's
not the main
issue here right the issue is aspects of
culture
and behavior and personal responsibility
so i think a much better message rather
than telling people that
the system is out to get them or the
game is rigged against them or
whatnot which you can't really
do anything about firstly i don't think
it's true or if it is it's
to a very light degree and i think most
people would want to get it so that it's
com
completely gone i think everyone's on
the same page on that but um
the you know everyone you can control
yourself it's a lot easier to control
yourself
than to control the whole system right
you want to overthrow capitalism you
want to get rid of this you want to
you don't most people don't have the
power to do that you've got a country of
300 and something million people it's
it's the way it is
and there's a lot of opportunity in this
country it comes back to that
perspective and gratitude thing right
there's so much opportunity even if
you're not coming from a great place
even if you're not coming from you know
the the top even if you're in the bottom
quartile to begin with
over the course of time several decades
i know you've talked about this a lot
right if people make good decisions
and avoid not even just make good
decisions but avoid making
really bad decisions then i do believe
that most people can
not most people i do believe that all
people can succeed to some degree
and be happy and be content and whatever
and not just be angry at all the time
and not be
getting more divided and falling back
more into tribal identity
and all that i mean it's just sad for me
to see that happen because
again i'm obsessed with the idea of
potential so when i'm i kind of see
potential and it's not being fulfilled
or people are
running around just doing and saying
things that aren't
helpful then i find it personally quite
frustrating so obviously you're not
american you've spent
some time in america but what is it what
is the perspective from abroad on
president trump upon whose shoulders
apparently all of world peace rests
what's your take on trump okay i can't
speak for the rest of the world
i can speak for myself personally um i'm
not going to try to give the whole uk
view or the whole abroad view i think
the uk view as a whole
is mostly negative
but not as negative as the press would
probably like to make people
believe there are a lot of trump
supporters or people who think he's
generally doing a good job
in the uk my personal view is that i
think he's doing a pretty good job
um in terms of what he's actually doing
in terms of his
you know i've been familiar with donald
trump for decades
so a lot of people are asking acting
like he's somebody just
brand new who's out there he's he's
always been brash he's always been
abrasive
he's always been pretty funny he's
always just been
you know a larger than life character
and he's continued to do that
as the president i mean personally i
think he's very funny
i think he's very very funny uh do i
agree with absolutely everything he says
no
but do i think it's good that someone's
in there kind of breaking the matrix
in a way yeah i do think it's good and
in terms of
his policies and the way the country
seems to be going in terms of the
economy and jobs and stuff like that
seems to be doing a decent job to me um
hasn't started any
super crazy new new crazy wars that i
know a lot of people were worried about
you know i do remember in 2016 when it
happened and
people were saying oh gosh this is going
to lead to world war 3 and it's going to
be
nuking north korea and we're going to be
in all these fights and battles and all
that and
i don't see it happening i don't see it
happening
and in terms of the opposition
they seem to be struggling to get
somebody who is better than him so as
as far as i'm saying you know even even
if people don't like his personality or
don't like some of the things that he
said or whatever
it's kind of like well if who's better
who who's better if he's that bad that
should be a really easy question
to answer and do you think that he's a
racist i mean he's obviously made
racially insensitive statements
he's uh he said things that i've
criticized on
on racial issues as at the very least
blind to
the meaning of what he's saying yeah
where do you where the media are
obviously all in on this
white supremacist that he's a racist
what do you make of that yeah but the
media thinks everyone's
i don't that is there i don't think that
donald trump is a racist
i don't know the man personally i know
people who have met him
um i don't believe he's a racist and the
fact that
he only suddenly became racist to people
in 2015 2016
despite being in the public eye for many
decades is really suspicious to me
in the world of hip-hop donald trump was
extremely popular i don't know how aware
you are of this not at all a lot of
rappers
a lot of rappers bigged up donald trump
in the night you should go back and
listen to hip-hop from from the 90s and
the thousands
donald trump was the guy right he was
the aspirational figure for
a lot of these rappers who are
entrepreneurial minded business-minded
wanted to go out hustle get that money
you know be the
be the ghetto version of trump or
whatever and that's a you know i think
jay-z has a lyric you know i'm the
hood's equivalent of trump or something
like that right
and then in again in 2015 2016 all this
suddenly changed very very quickly and i
think a lot of that was
was media driven so when it comes to
that i don't think he's a racist i don't
think he's a white supremacist
i think that he says dumb insensitive
stuff
sometimes that can certainly be it
certainly gives
his opponents and people who already
don't like him in the media
a way to take what something he said
um and give it a racial sort of
twist even when there wasn't a great
example would be um i don't know like
the thing he said about baltimore say
being rad infested
to me that has zero racial condensations
at all if someone says a place is rat
interested i i'm just like okay it's a
rat infested
right but then people were saying oh he
used the word infested that
somehow implies i mean that's a pretty
racist interpretation
of it if you're saying oh he said that
because i was like
my brain didn't even you know i mean my
my brain didn't even go that way
so i think sometimes they you know that
he's had like maybe one or two
statements where it's been like
that was borderline but i don't think i
think it's more
i think he's been occasionally in he's
insensitive in a lot of ways
you know he can be insensitive towards
uh
towards women or towards you know
minority demographics or anything i just
think he's an
equal opportunities offender i don't
think it's targeted
at okay we're going to go after that
group of people or that group of people
or anything like that i just think he
says a lot of stuff he tweets a lot of
stuff
some of it is dumb and but i don't i
said i don't i don't know the man
personally
but given what i do know i don't think
that's what's in his heart so you
mentioned rap so now we have to talk
about it
so the elephant in the room is that i
have tweeted many times about how much i
hate rap so
my view of this is shaped by the fact
that i have the cultural profile of a
bond villain
meaning that i if i drank alcohol it
would be brandy from a snifter
i've played classical violin since i was
five years old i own a nice violin
my dad is a professional pianist we play
proms together and so
i grew up listening to classical music
almost entirely
some broadway maybe say well not maybe
so a lot of classic jazz like oscar
peterson
uh but apparently number one do you
think that it's racist not to like rap
because i've been told that if i do not
like rap
then this is because i do not like black
people which i find shocking since i
particularly like jazz which
is a black art form so can we just can
we just
swage my fears here that i'm not a
racist for not for not liking rap and
then you can convince me that i'm
actually wrong about rap
yeah i know i i think you're wrong i
definitely don't think it's racist
uh no this is this is the thing people
people say such crazy stuff i don't get
how someone can
jump also twitter has changed in radical
ways like it used to be that 10 years
ago you could make a joke about rap
rap not being music and you're stupid if
you disagree and people are like oh
that's a joke
and now it's like no you meant that you
hate black people like whoa where are
the
people people people really read
non-existent
malice and non-existent interpretations
into things people say it's just a weird
trend which i do hope goes away because
it's really
annoying and also it's it makes it
difficult to
take those words seriously okay if
someone
you know you're an orthodox jew if
someone says that you're you're a nazi
or
you're a white supremacist or i've been
called a white supremacist if someone's
you know
calls everything racist everything
sexist then it really dilutes those
terms to the point where
i don't even know what these things mean
anymore everybody's been called far
right everybody's been called all right
if someone actually is legitimately
far-right or a legitimate neo-nazi i'd
like to know you know who that person is
but if you're just going to call
everybody that then you're just
providing cover for the real bad guys so
i do
wish people would kind of chill on that
kind of rhetoric okay so my case against
rap
is i have the musical case against trap
and then i'll get to the cultural case
so the musical case against rap is that
in in my view
and the view of my music theorist father
who who went to
music school the there are three
elements to music there is
harmony there is there is melody and
there is rhythm and rap only fulfills
one of these
the rhythm section that there's not a
lot of melody and there's not a lot of
harmony
and thus it is basically effectively
spoken rhythm
and so it's not actually a form of music
it's a it's a form of rhythmic speaking
uh and thus i and so beyond the
subjectivity of me just not enjoying
rap all that much it's what i've said
before is not music so tell me why i'm
wrong
well there's certainly melody in the
beats and even some
rappers rapping singing certainly has a
melody i'm not a particularly melodic
rapper myself
there are artists who sort of sing rap a
lot more
but i'd certainly say in terms of the
the production there's
a lot of harmony and melody in there
in terms of wrapping itself obviously
rapping is a different art from singing
so the focus is on the rhythm rather
than on
the melodies and the harmonies by
intention otherwise you'd be
singing right i'm not too great at
harmony and melody
and people don't want to nobody would
pay to see me on stage thinking
but uh in terms of the the lyricism and
the the rhythm that's really where the
skill lies
so as an art form it's um i mean it's a
really unique form of music in
a lot of ways one i think is that
you've just got the space to express
yourself
you and in hip-hop you can you can
really rap about anything you can make a
song about absolutely
anything you could you can make a
political rap song you can make
a rap song about love or romance
and any topic a lot lots of genres of
music you're somewhat restricted
in terms of what you can talk about and
express lyrically
um whereas in hip-hop that's just
totally wide open and
as i'm sure you know people use that for
a whole bunch of different things you've
got you've got your your gangster rap
you've got your
um a positive sort of conscious rap
you've got you've got your deep stuff
you can tell life stories you can just
share opinions on on pretty much
anything and so it's really really
unique in
that sense um and yeah i think it's i
think it's a little bit like
they're very different music forms but i
think it's a little bit like country
in that regard in the way that you can
kind of make a song about
anything and the people who write the
lyrics tend to be the
same people who perform them whereas in
genres like pop and even rock it's
not uncommon to have a separate
songwriter who then provides that to the
person who sings it
so with hip hop what you're really
getting is the artist's own
expression so i can go away i could
write a song and what
what someone's listening to is really
just the mind of zooby just like they
can listen to this conversation this
interview
and they're getting what's going on in
my mind it's the same if they go and
they listen to the lyrics of my songs
they know okay this is the story he's
telling this is where he's coming from
that's where his heart is
um in terms of the music aspect to it
whether or not you
like that it vibes with you and you're
feeling with that i mean that's
that's totally subjective so my some
other kind of artistic criticism of rap
is
maybe a stereotype about how rap is
written so i i have this this kind of
theory and it holds true across
all musical form which is that art and
craft are not in opposition
but very often they seem to be placed in
opposition meaning there's
a and this leads to my criticism of rock
along the same lines as my criticism of
rap which was that rock was an actual
degradation of skill for
for music from jazz which was actually a
degradation of skill from classical that
the amount of talent and and work mostly
work that you have to put into mastering
a classical instrument
is a lot higher than the amount of
talent that you and work you'd have to
put into playing three chords
uh in in a rock song and and so when it
comes to
the the lyrics in rap maybe i'm sure
part of it is because i just don't have
a lot of experience
but it seems like that there's a lot of
praise that's put out for particular
rappers who it seems to me are doing
something that doesn't seem
innately very difficult it doesn't seem
like the the lyrics
have exact rhyme i have this criticism
of even i mean in
musical theater this is one of my
criticisms with emmanuel miranda
actually is that he doesn't use exact
rhyme enough
he uses near rhymes and he and he uses
sort of easier forms of rhyme very often
and stacks lyrics in order to make
things sound more complex
than they are and then you watch movies
about rap but it seems like somebody
just gets up on the mic and they just go
and it's and how much work actually goes
into crafting
uh a rap lyric how much time has to go
into
figuring out the rhythmic scheme and the
rhyme scheme
because i think that would change my
opinion somewhat on how rap is
constructed sure this
really depends on the rapper to be
totally honest with you there are
rappers who
i would tota i would totally agree do
not spend
do not spend much time or thought or
energy
in crafting what they're saying right
they just put something together and
it's a very basic rhyme scheme and
they'll just go there and it'll be quite
repetitive
in terms of the content there's not
really any decent message in there
they're not
telling any story they're not using any
clever wordplay or anything like that
so to me that's what makes a bad rapper
um
if you were to take uh a great rapper i
don't know
nas eminem jay-z someone like that whose
lyrics are a lot more
complex and in-depth then you know i'd
like to or myself of course i'd like to
think
uh a lot of thought goes a lot goes into
it a lot goes into it in terms of the
the rhythmic patterns and what you'd
call the flow which is essentially how
you how you ride
the beat so if you've got a beat that's
a faster tempo
you might wrap it double double the
speed and
have your you're you're essentially
using your voice kind of like a
percussive
instrument it might be more comparable
to drumming say
than to um in terms in terms of the
delivery
right but then in terms of the actual
lyrical content for me that for
for a great artist that's where the real
thought comes in
and again when it comes to hip-hop if
you're making a hip-hop song
average rap song probably has eight to
ten
times the amount of lyrics if not more
as pretty much any other genre so you
you've got a lot of stuff typically
you'll have
three 16 bar verses so you've got a lot
of space to say
a lot of stuff if you want to i mean
some artists don't
don't don't say much i like to think you
know in all my songs i put a lot of
thought
into what i'm saying and the message i'm
trying to communicate out there and
there's a lot of wordplay and
a lot of metaphors and similes and just
trying to do clever stuff with the
writing
so again i think that the real answer to
that is it depends on
the rapper just like you could have
somebody who does a very
basic form of dance or playing an
instrument and they're just okay i'm
gonna just play the piano
like yeah like that versus someone who's
a
proper virtuoso you do get the same
thing
um in in hip hop and with rap um it's
funny with my parents
my parents used to be a little bit
disparaging of rap and hip-hop until i
started doing it
and they saw me performing and were like
how was he doing that
yeah that's where they're really like
okay that's that's a talent okay so
let's talk about the cultural critique
of of hip-hop and
rap so for a long time in the united
states there's been
criticism and i think some of it is
well-founded about the messages that are
pervaded by by hip-hop and rap and you
know they're folks like candace owens on
the right who have
critiqued my critique of hip-hop they've
said that i'm not really seeing a lot of
the deeper messages in hip-hop
she particularly likes to talk about the
value of
capitalism and success in hip-hop she
says that like to cite the trump example
the emulation of success in hip-hop is
really strong and she sees that as a
strong positive
from from the outside when i listen to
hip-hop i i don't hear a lot of
family-oriented messages in fact i hear
a lot of messages
that are degrading to women i hear
messages that push violence
uh that are disparaging to the police uh
i hear messages very often that seem to
treat relationships between men and
women as something disposable or or
glorify mistreatment
of women and that's not a criticism of
your part because obviously
i want to discuss your messages in a
second but the the art form overall
which
obviously has a major impact not just on
on black young people
but is disproportionately listened to
actually by white young people i i don't
particularly like a lot of the messages
that i hear in in hip hop
by the way i've made similar criticisms
of pop music which i think does a lot of
the same things
what do you make of that particular
critique you're not going to get a lot
of pushback from me on that one
because i think you're correct
especially in terms of the popular
mainstream stuff that gets
pushed out there hard a lot of the stuff
that gets the promotion that people will
hear on the radio or
in nightclubs and stuff like that a lot
of it does have
a lot of negative messaging um part of
that is the reason why from the the very
beginning
of my music career i was like i'm gonna
do the opposite of that
because it's something that that's there
i think that
i think it's a it's a truth in
entertainment in general
i don't think that's something that is i
think compared to other genres you might
get
more of that in the in the hip-hop art
form and i think a lot of that is
you know down to the artist and where
they're coming from and whatnot um
but a lot of it is also what people want
to it's a weird supply and demand thing
as well this is something i've
questioned myself for a very long time
is how much of this is this is what
people are demanding
and so artists are just continuing to
supply it because
it works people might say oh we don't
like the misogynistic messages we don't
like the drugs we don't like the
violence but people are dancing to it
and buying it and purchasing it and
so people are going to keep on making it
so i don't know how much of it
is just that versus how much is you know
record companies and
people in power in the entertainment
industry and whatnot wanting
those to be the messages that get the
push out there because there's a lot of
positive hip-hop out there
it's a lot of positive hip-hop that's
not degrading at all that's non-violent
that's not profane
but a lot of the time it doesn't get the
same push it doesn't get the same shine
it's not being embraced by all these
mainstream channels and that's something
that
for 20 years i've been looking at and
thinking that's
that's interesting why why is that so i
don't really know how much of it is
artist driven versus fan driven beyond
hip-hop
like i said i think it's it's a an issue
in entertainment in general whether
you're talking
all forms of music certainly pop music
as well like you said
video games movies tv there's
a lot of stuff that's put out there
which is
certainly questionable um
and it's it's a funny one for me because
to some degree i'm like
it's just entertainment and you know
the truth is for whatever reason we
humans i think especially guys do
like to some degree we do like violence
we you know we do like sex we do like
you know yeah we do like gangster movies
where you're you're kind of rooting for
the bad guy and whatnot
which that doesn't mean you go out there
in real life and that's the right
no you you go out there and you behave
that way you see this thing when people
are saying oh do violent video games
cause people to commit violence and
stuff the evidence doesn't seem to show
that's the case but
i'll do stuff in a video game that i
wouldn't dream of i would
dream of doing in real life i mean i
don't even swear i don't even swear i've
been listening to profane hip-hop for
the best part of my life and i don't
even cuss and i get people who are like
how do you not how can you listen to all
this and you don't even
i'm like it doesn't just doesn't affect
me it's just entertainment to me it gets
me pumped up to do my workouts in the
gym or whatever
so i know me myself personally i'm
certainly able to separate that
um can everybody do it i don't know
really how much effect does it have on
people i don't know really
i do wonder whether rap does just as an
art form because it is verbally based as
opposed like
you can listen to a pop a pop song and
you can sing the pop song without
knowing any of the lyrics yeah whereas
it would be impossible to do that with a
rap song because obviously the lyrics
are the entirety of the song
or at least the vast majority of the
song i wonder if the verbalization
and the and the identification with the
words is stronger in hip-hop than it
would be with with other genres for
example
it could be it could be i mean the way i
look at it to be totally honest
is i make positive inspirational
motivational hip-hop music
and i've had people tell me in real life
and online
that they've been directly influenced or
inspired in a positive way by my music
so if that can exist it must be possible
that the opposite
can also exist and that there can be
negative influences and impacts from
certain messages being put out there
in hip-hop and other forms of art so can
you talk about one of the
because i'm sure most of my listeners
most of the people who
are watching this haven't heard any of
your stuff so can you talk about some of
the messages that you include in some of
your songs
yeah sure thing so the overarching theme
of my music really is about
um individual individuality
authenticity honesty pursuing your
dreams
overcoming obstacles
that's really what i like to share my
own story so every album
is sort of a snapshot of where i was at
that particular stage of my life and my
career
and trying to express that every single
song is different i've got some songs
where
the message is quite light and it's not
obviously this is like a super positive
inspirational song
um but i've got somewhere i think it's
it's a lot clearer
and if you certainly if you listen to
the entire body of work the full album
i think most people would come away
thinking okay that was an inspirational
positive thing i mean the truth is in
life you've got you've got good and bad
you've got positive and negative not
everything is happy-go-lucky
you know yeah so so you've got to have
that
that balance and that side of things
sometimes you are feeling mad sometimes
you are feeling
aggressive sometimes you're feeling
upset and you can go and express that in
a song
but other times cool like something
great has happened i want to celebrate
i'm feeling triumphant
i just want to be sometimes in hip-hop
you even just want to be yourself up you
just want to be you know what i've
i've done something cool i'm doing
something great i'm the best like i'm
dope
you know and some you get that as well
you just get that braggadocious kind of
rap where it's just like yeah i'm
awesome
right in hip-hop you can just make a
whole song about how cool you are and
most most rappers have several
of these and um yeah it could be deemed
like a little bit
cocky or arrogant or whatever but it
does also pump people up
right it it makes people listen to that
whether they're they're going to work or
they're in the gym or whatever
and it motivates and it inspires them
when you're hearing the story especially
with
you know some some of these rappers
stories i think it's always interesting
to look at
a lot of times and even what we've been
doing is focusing on the words because a
lot of people
ask about rappers and i guess other
public figures as
role models you know what's the degree
of responsibility should
should a rapper be a role model that
kind of thing
and to me i mean my biggest role models
are my parents god bless them but um in
terms of rappers
there are a lot of rappers i am inspired
by some of them not so much by their
lyrics but by what they've actually done
in their life and i do sometimes wish
that they
themselves and even the media sort of
focused on that a little bit i mean i
sort of feel this way about jc and
beyonce honestly like i look at them
they're unbelievably successful
they're married they have kids together
like they seem like they're living a
pretty traditional lifestyle but
when i listen to any of their music that
is not exactly what i'm getting from the
music
yeah i mean jay-z i mean the guy
literally went from
selling drugs in in the streets of new
york
to becoming he's a billionaire now you
know and
independently he created created his own
company put out his own records
created his own clothing line beverage
brands like all these
sponsorship deals he he's done all this
crazy stuff he's got you know
his basketball chair yeah yeah exactly
so
that's super inspiring like in that
sense that's totally a role model if
you're going to go and listen to
you know big pimpin and
go through come through the lyrics of
that and try to find like something but
then yeah maybe not so you know or even
guys like 50 cent you know in terms of
being a businessman and an entrepreneur
and really going from rags to riches
something to nothing
super duper inspiring i in a way i wish
they'd put more of that directly in
their music because i kind of feel
there's two ways to look at them you can
focus on the lyrics and
some of the words and some of the things
they're saying and be like oh that's a
that's a terrible role model
but you could also look at what they've
actually done and their life story and
be like oh wow like
this person is thinking i've heard the
same thing about it i feel the same way
about snoop dogg frankly i mean the guy
that guy has been incredibly successful
he
he's got a really close relationship
with his with his kids as far as i'm
aware
and again you listen to the music and in
something completely different
and i wish that what success every
successful person follows a similar path
which is you work hard and you keep your
head down
and you do something you're good at and
people want you to do and
then when it comes to the messages that
are pervaded it's it's almost
in many cases the complete opposite of
that it's rebel against the system the
system is the problem it's like well it
was within the system that you became
the owner of an nba team so
i'm pretty sure that the system is pro
probably you should just encourage
people to do
what you did which was to work hard and
make creative decisions and invest in
yourself
yeah i like i said i wish i don't know
all these guys personally
i wish they would make that more
explicit
and prominent in their their music and
their their messaging
because sometimes it's you you'll watch
an interview with them
and you'll listen to the songs and it's
almost like quite a different person
like in the interviews you're really
getting
that story and that that positive vibe
but then sometimes in the music not all
the time you know there's lots of these
guys do have some positive songs here
and there and whatnot
but um yeah it's it's it's a tricky one
at the end of the day
like we've been saying i can only
control what you do what i do
and the content that i put out there i
can't police everybody
else nor what i really want to be able
to um
but i think there's a lot of positive
and inspiration that can be gleaned
if you sort of look at it the right way
or you look at it a certain way i don't
mean to put you on the spot or make you
do a show for us or anything but what's
you what's your favorite song that
you've written and what's your favorite
lyric
wow um one of my favorite songs there's
a few of them one of my favorite songs
i've written
lyrically is called um ill
and uh the second verse of that is
definitely
one of my favorites i'm i'm going to see
if i can uh
i'm not in like rap mode right now
exactly that's what i'm saying
um i've got it's like what about my
violin yeah
or even the first verse it's um i've got
a lot to give so i can't live with trial
later
life's got a lot to live in so i give to
die major a moon walk through the fire
laugh now cry later i've got pupils to
inspire so i hope to die later
a couple words can turn a total stranger
to a neighbor like a little thot can
turn a tiny building to a scraper
i wonder if the biggest trees have got
the biggest haters like we started out
from seeds now we're the source of all
this paper
um so yeah i've got i've got a lot of
stuff like that
um it's so weird for me to shift from
motor to rap mode it is really
weird
it's like a different part of my brain
i'm trying to access um
so yeah that's one of my favorites ill
um i've got another song called remember
the name which is one of my favorites
and um another song called glory so
those are probably three three of my
favorite ones out there i've put out a
lot of music so
how are your parents dealing with the
fact that you decided not to be a
management consultant
and be a rapper instead well they were
at my last show so they're definitely
supportive
they're very very supportive of what i
do um and
yeah they they trust me they believe in
me they know they know what my message
is
as well and they're genuine fans of the
music itself
um and they like what i do they know the
message i'm putting out there they've
seen how it
impacts people and how it's had a
positive impact on young people and
whatnot
so they're they're truly supportive and
um i'm very very grateful for it
especially as nigerian parents i know
that it's quite rare for uh
you know to have a son who went to
oxford and then have him go and pursue
something
that as artistic and creative as music
but uh they're behind me 100 my family
really supports me which is
a huge blessing because if they didn't i
think things would be a lot more
difficult okay so i like to fancy myself
you know a man with the body of greek
god i work out every day
and uh and then i meet somebody like you
and i feel like a fat ass frankly
uh so so how does your exercise routine
work yeah
um i lift a lot of heavy weights a lot
of compound exercises
um deadlifts bench press squat overhead
press pull ups
stuff like that that's what 80 90 of my
workouts consist of
and then um then then the diet depending
on what i'm trying to do whether i'm
trying to
build or gain or just maintain these
last several years it's really
been more about maintenance and then
occasionally going on a cut to shed some
body fat if i've
you know put on a few pounds over the
winter like most people naturally do
so it's it's fairly simple fairly simple
but the thing that's really key
is consistency just like with everything
else both with training and with diet
it's really about consistency i mean
i've been
going to the gym now for about 16 or 17
years i started really early i didn't
really know what i was doing
in my mid-teens but i used to play rugby
so i started because i wanted to get a
little more buff
for rugby so i could deal the damage
rather than sustain it
my programming is pretty simple it's not
it's not super complicated in my book i
keep things
pretty simple i don't want to make it
really complex
and in-depth i don't like to throw out
stuff that people
don't need and won't necessarily
understand but yeah primarily
compound lifts um decently high
intensity in terms of the weights
not doing too much not doing too many
what i call fluff exercises
so just little things that won't get you
much bang for your buck just focusing on
the big heavy hard stuff
what are the fluff exercises fluff
exercises like tricep kickbacks and uh
i don't know wrist curls and yeah just
anything involving pink dumbbells
[Laughter]
so yeah i focus on that and then just
keep the diet on point
what's your diet like um quite flexible
quite flexible i kind of follow a little
bit of an 80 20 rule which is that as
long as
80 of what i'm eating is nutritious and
good then
the other 20 can be not super
amazing if if i'm trying to lean down
then i'll dial it in a little bit just
to
you know bring bring my calories down
and whatnot well what's what's normal
caloric intake
for me to maintain my weight about 3 300
3 400 a day
um if i want to diet i bring it down to
like 2 900 3
000 how many hours a day are you working
out uh one hour
every couple one hour how do i get into
this because i
i'm seriously i'm going working out like
an hour a day and then i'm looking at my
my app and it's like you have 1400
calories or you will gain weight
what the hell so i can have an apple and
a banana and like an almond
like no that's not a thing that's going
to happen another great thing is
intermittent fasting i don't know if
you've ever tried that m m jewish that's
just part of our religion but okay yeah
but yeah i mean how often is it
intermittent fast um so i normally have
about an eight-hour eating window so
i'll normally faster about 16 hours a
day
and then i'll eat all my calories
normally between 10 and 6 or
11 and 7 something like that and then
outside of that i don't
eat or drink is it a heavy meat diet or
more vegetables
um i good amount of protein um probably
about
two roughly a gram per pound of body
weight in terms of protein
and then i kind of just fill up the rest
of my caloric intake with
primarily carbs and some fats i find
that
the ratio of those doesn't impact me too
much um
i need more tips i need to read your
entire book this sounds fantastic to me
frankly because i keep hearing i have to
eat nothing but vegetables
and and i'll be honest i've given up on
the six six-pack like i just figure it's
never going to happen i think that my
body
i'm going to blame it on my body type in
my genetics even though that's probably
just giving up on life
but yeah so it's not um it's
that's really what i've tried to lay out
in the book is to show that it's not
super duper complex and you don't need
to
eat just rabbit food you can actually
enjoy foods that you like
while still hitting your numbers and
reaching your targets and
not to the detriment of your performance
and your the way you feel and perform
and everything like that
so depending on how big somebody is
generally is going to determine how many
calories they can
have in total along with their activity
level um
so if you're bigger and more active you
can kind of get away
with eating more more naturally and you
don't need to be quite as
precise and strict as someone who's got
only 2 000 calories to to work with
might
but um yeah the foods themselves
are important from a nutritional
standpoint but in terms of just
macronutrients and protein carb fat
breakdown
there's a whole lot of flexibility you
can have in there it's like there's a
couple of key rules that matter
and then everything outside of that is
sort of details people get bogged down
in the details people say
what time of the day should i go to the
gym how many meals a day should i eat
how big she that stuff doesn't really
matter
in the in the grand scheme of things you
know go to the gym when you can get to
the gym
in terms of how many meals you eat
that's up to you some people prefer six
some people prefer two i know people who
only eat one meal a day
and as long as you're getting the
nutrients in there and you're hitting
the numbers that you need to be hitting
then you'll be all right
some people will just feel better with
different frequencies of meals and
depending on one's lifestyle
that'll also determine it as well what
do you make of the various fitness
crazes so i know that my my trainer has
sort of
uh gotten into crossfit and has me doing
some of the crossfit exercises um
it sounds like i mean you've been saying
that you're picking up very heavy
weights i've always been fearful that if
i pick up heavy weights i'm going to
totally injure myself and wrap myself up
what do you make of that
um crossfit there's a lot of crossfit
jokes out there
sure you've heard a few of them um look
michael you have to brag about it right
within five seconds of being
in the social setting you have to say
that it's like being a vegan exactly
vegan well only things that don't cast a
shadow
yeah so i think ultimately anything that
gets people
active and going and exercising as far
as i'm concerned is
a good thing um in terms of the way i
train like i said i keep it kind of
fairly simple old school medium potatoes
lift heavy objects
put them down and that that primarily
works but in terms of the crazes again
it's
i i don't know i don't i don't want to
be too critical because
it's like if something works if
something works and people enjoy it
then keep doing it you don't need to
like
lots of my training is powerlifting
based and powerlifting is only based
around
squatting deadlifting and bench pressing
which i understand for a lot of people
will get
boring really really quickly and if
you're not competing in those lifts then
you don't need to just limit yourself to
those ones in terms of lifting heavy
though i mean heavy's firstly a relative
thing
so i recommend people lifting relatively
heavy to
what they're capable of so that could be
anywhere from
70 to 85 of their one rep maximum
for example and you might do that for
three reps or five reps or six
six reps or something like that in terms
of injury risk it's not
huge as long as you lift correctly
a lot of the injuries come from people
just not
doing the lift the right way so that's
not a problem with
the weights or lifting in general did
you work with a trainer for a while to
make sure that you're lifting correctly
or you sort of figured it out
at the very very early stage i would
talk to the gym instructors
and just make sure i was doing stuff
right but i'm it's largely self-taught
for me
it's largely self-taught and i've done
it for so long now i mean i've also done
a personal training qualification so
i'm actually qualified you know to train
other people and
i've just spent i've done my ten
thousand i put in my 10 thousand hours
so for me at this point it's kind of
like simple this is how you do a squat
that's how you do a deadlift this is how
you do a bench press and whatnot
um but i think a lot of people don't do
the exercises
correctly and you get a lot of people
who want to lift with the ego
rather than with the muscles so they'll
rack up 50
more weight than they should probably
have on the bar and then they'll start
bringing their back into it and
lifting arching their back on a bench
press and doing all this crazy stuff or
doing these quarter squats instead of
actually going all the way down
there's a lot of things that people do
and it's it's best to again
strip it back to the basics and just
learn to do the movements properly
and then once you've got that down then
you can start
sort of cranking it as somebody's
obviously very helpful oriented what do
you make of the body positivity movement
so this has obviously become a big thing
lately
right you've got all these people who
are basically saying however you look
that's that's that's fine
and it's good and any critique of
anybody along any
lines is a bad idea and i mean frankly i
found that
it is feeling fat that has gotten me to
go to the gym like
that feeling out of shape and feeling
like i don't look good is it bigger
whenever people say well you want to
work out so that you feel healthy and
it's like well but you don't know what
it's like to feel healthy until you
actually feel healthy especially when
you start working out it feels like
garbage right i mean when
when you first start it just feels awful
and then later
it actually starts to feel really good
and you always hear that from people but
that's not much of a motivator it feels
like for
a lot of folks looking good is actually
kind of an important thing and as we get
rid of those standards
it may not be a great thing for the
health of the society yeah it's weird
i think society in general is trying to
get rid of standards for sort of
anything and i think the body positive
positivity thing is just another symptom
of that sort of another branch of the
let's just do away with aspiring
to anything it doesn't matter what you
look like doesn't matter how much you
weigh you can still be healthy you can
still it's like that's not actually
true so firstly my first condemnation of
it is that that's just not
it's not correct you can't actually be
healthy at any size that's not true
like if you are morbidly obese you're
not healthy you're putting yourself at
risk of
a lot of diseases different types of
cancers diabetes all that kind of stuff
so
encouraging or i don't want to say
allowing's not the right word
encouraging or condoning
that is not good for individuals let
alone
the people outside of them or if you're
in the i live in the uk you've got the
nhs
you've got subsidized medical healthcare
so actually someone being morbidly obese
that does
actually affect other people too right
because it costs tens of billions
of pounds to the nhs every year
so i don't think that's what you want to
be encouraging like a lot of these
things i think that
a kernel of it comes from a good place
of
sympathy and kindness and saying yeah
you know you don't
i'm not in favor of bullying people i
don't think you should be
you know find someone who's overweight
and be pointing at them and saying
saying i mean or what
being mean to them or anything like that
but um as someone who was
previously fat a lot of people don't
know this as someone who was really fat
uh i'm quite glad
that i felt a little bit of shame and i
wasn't totally happy with
how i looked and that was the first
thing it's not what necessarily kept me
in the gym
but it's what got me going in the first
place of being like man i can
i can do better i can look better i can
feel better and then it got me started i
started seeing some results and it was
like okay cool just became a habit
and kept going with that so i think you
should give yourself a reason
to be body positive not just because you
exist and you breathe air
but because you've put in some
semblance of effort to you know you
don't need to maximize
your appearance and your health but at
least take care of it you only get one
body
and you've got to live with it for the
rest of your life so even if it's not
about the aesthetics and what you look
like and looking hot and sexy
it's just about actually being healthy
and having a
working heart that keeps going and your
liver and your kidneys and all that
stuff then
yeah do it especially if you've if
you've got a family or
a spouse or whatever it's even more
important because you should want to
live a good life not just for yourself
live a good long life for yourself and
your children as well so in a second i
want to ask you about your religious
worldview which we haven't touched on
at all but first if you want to hear
zubi's answer you have to be a daily
wire subscriber to subscribe head on
over to dailywire.com click subscribe
you can hear the end
of our conversation over there well
zooby i really want to thank you for
stopping by everybody should go check
out zubi's book strong advice zubi's
guide to fitness for everybody he's got
a podcast as well real talk with zubi
and listen to his music
on spotify and apple music i'll be
giving it a try zooby thanks so much
really appreciate your i appreciate it
[Music]
ben shapiro show sunday special is
directed by mathis glover and produced
by jonathan hay
executive producer jeremy boring
associate producer colton haas
our guests are booked by caitlin maynard
post production is supervised by alex
zingaro
editing by donovan fowler audio is mixed
by mike caromina
hair and makeup is by jesua olvera title
graphics by cynthia angulo the ben
shapiro show sunday special is a daily
wire production
copyright daily wire 2019